one groom-to-be its anxiously anxiously
awaiting Drake's RSVP so let's set this
up this guy named Jacob hawk Dean Drake
on Instagram he wrote hey Drake my
fiance and I are getting married on
September 22nd she's your biggest fan
and I wanted to surprise her how many
likes or follows for you to perform a
couple songs at her wedding it would
mean the world to us and Drake reply the
hero first off congrats on getting
married and 1 million likes and 100,000
followers good luck and Jacob wrote back
oh my gosh you've actually responded I
will try my very hardest to get that
goal thank you so much you're a great
guy so the challenge was on and in just
six days the numbers far surpassed
Drake's challenge the account has 240
1000 followers and the post is 1.2
million likes so now the ball was in
Drake's court if he's actually going to
go people are also doubting if this is
legit so the Instagram account is called
Drake wedding there's no other post on
the account so people thought maybe
Drake set this up for some good PR and
he already knows the guy you can't also
didn't have the guy's name on it he says
he created a new Instagram account to
hide this from his fiancee Wow Jacob
Hawk reveals his identity and called
into Roz's radio show this morning
the rosna mocha show too sure people
it's real and he's just waiting to hear
from Drake now so is this real or what
yeah man this is real I mean a surreal
but it's real so what's next you reach
out to Drake yet this morning to be like
Sam it's done like here's the address
little every day since he sent me to IBM
try hitting him up he hasn't responded
yet maybe maybe he has more stuff going
on but so far he hasn't responded yet he
hasn't seen it either
I believe Drake in his word you know
that we hit the goal he'll come out and
perform that's what I believe in these
but your message I think is what come on
buddy respond let's good it looks good
something worked out my friend I'd love
to see it love to have you my fiance
basically my wife we met on Xbox for
years I mean it'd be incredible tabby
there we've been fans for a very long
time I'll tell you what you worry where
your whole mission fails and I just
figured it out I'm just going
I'm just going through his message again
what you didn't say how much to perform
for free at my wedding if we can pay a
little pay him I got money
that he and his fiancee met on xbox I
have so I tooked I applaud that where's
mine our social media Atlanta says yes
to make it now curious I think you will
make sisters drink Avenue of wedding
songs well I mean a lot of his catalogue
could be considered that they're like
party songs like romantic like first
dance songs not like a first dance song
per se but like romantic ish Dancy songs
right quite a bit yeah
pirate says that would be cool if he
does a random time says she probably
won't to go I'm just trying to look out
on dance one dance I mean I need a one
dance I just try to look up his like to
or dates yes coming up September 14th
he's in Las Vegas September 27th he's in
Brazil
wait when is the wedding supposed to be
with 20 seconds yes so I can't find a
list of like his actual like tour dates
if he's gotta be somewhere everybody
gotta put Blake Blake
sorry put Drake on glass Blake make sure
he knows that he's got to go to this
wedding but yeah so just passed it last
night he was just last night this is
finally hit its goal so yeah now Drake
has to respond I think he was prepared
that this could happen yeah he knows the
guys gonna post it and someone said that
Drake actually posted on his Instagram
story as well obviously I'm not sure if
that's true
well that would have definitely right
now or that yes a little bit either way
you have to assume that this it's likely
gonna happen like remember AMA says of
game plan oh what a great story about
goal setting right right it was like I'm
gonna set this goal great I'm gonna go
I'm gonna go do it right gets it done
and lets you know where's the pea yeah
with the pan yes so he has to go now
okay I think he'll show up cuz it look
pretty bad now if he's like no not there
so up also what a party I was gonna want
to go to that wedding be careful don't
tell anyone where the wedding is now
because if Drake is coming to your
wedding like this this is the fiance
know now like now that he revealed his
name you went on Rajas radio show is
this still secret I guess not same I
guess you follow those and so what's
gonna happen now you got to get Drake
yeah exactly
now Elena just as Drake might forget I
don't supposed to show up in the
beginning he was visit our garage mokey
he's like I don't know here's he might
have other stuff to do like you might
add or going on but hey September 22nd
look out my calendars everybody and
we're all going to a wedding yeah